Every breakup sucks while some are worse than others. They all affect us in one form or another
Whether it was an amicable or fury induced split will provide you with solid tips on how to get over your ex
1.) cut off contact at least for a while whether you're the dumper or the dumpy
It's not healthy to keep tabs on your ex. Once the relationship is over (but everyone still does it)
You might want to be mature and remain on friendly terms with your ex
But you won't give yourself enough time to heal from the break-up
Tell your ex that you'll need space for a while
You should also consider trimming them from your social media feeds by unfollowing or muting their activity to prevent potential
instances of jealousy
nostalgia, or target of passive aggression
2.) take up a new hobby being newly single doesn't have to be a bad thing
When you're in a relationship you have less time for yourself since much of it is devoted to your partner on
The other hand when you're single, you can get to know yourself more intimately
You're free to discover your interests and dedicate your time to whatever you want
Is there a particular class or hobby that you've always wanted to participate in perhaps its animation
painting puzzles
Gardening sports a book club or even the theater the possibilities are endless
Learning a new skill and acquiring a new purpose will boost your self-esteem and independence
Three pamper yourself
Indulge yourself in junk food and sappy movies since your ex won't be there to treat you anymore. Take a vacation
Take a week or a weekend to relax somewhere with your friends
Take a spa day and rid yourself of the daily stresses that pile on top of your relationship loss
4. be real with yourself use your time alone to reflect on your relationship before the break-up though
You may have positive memories of your partner and the time you spent together
It is important to remember that there were problems that inevitably drove you to a part while you might want to fix things
except that the two of you might simply be
Incompatible and that breaking up was the best course of action in the long run
Five vent to your loved ones. It is important to have a decent support system to help you through a breakup
When you're feeling angry or hurt your friends can justify your feelings and remind you that you're not alone
You might even share some of their own illuminating experiences
Additionally research shows that merely verbalizing your feelings can make negative emotions less intense
Six listen to sad music
During a breakup. Your brain is actually attracted to sad music
When an artist you've never met can articulate your exact thoughts and feelings through words and sounds it's proof that you're not alone
You're a human sharing in a human experience
Moreover a recent study has found that sad songs can actually elicit peacefulness in the listener
It can also make us cry, which can be cathartic and mood boosting
So go ahead and listen to that breakup playlist on repeat
7 except the past if your breakup was less than amicable
You might be harboring some regret and hostility towards your ex
Allow yourself the time necessary to grieve, but be careful not to let it consume your identity
Emotional grudges not only contribute to feelings of depression and anxiety
But they will negatively impact your future relationships
Forgive your ex forgive yourself and move on
Eight. It's okay to still love your ex
The worst part of a breakup is the dissonance from hurting over your ex's actions yet hurting that they're gone
Breaking up doesn't mean that the love between you is completely dead
Whether it's been a few years or a few months, the two of you made memories together and played significant roles in each other's lives
Unfortunately love just isn't enough and there are many things that factor into making a relationship work
Understand that love sometimes means wanting the best for each other and sometimes that means breaking up
9. feel good about the rebound a
2014 study found that people who rebounded with a new partner after a breakup
Reported a better sense of well-being than those who stayed single for long periods of time afterwards
However, the rebounds in this study happened approximately
seven months after their first breakup
Therefore while it's important for you to heal before moving on stay open to new possibilities
Don't turn away a new chance at love because you're hung up on your ex
Breakups are always hard, but they aren't impossible to get through you can do it
Do you have any tips to share that aren't on this list? Feel free to share them by writing in the comments section down below?
Thanks for watching